نحن نقف الان هنا في مخيم جباليا شمال قطع
غزه حيث الوضع الانساني يزداد سوءا يوما
بعد يوم مع تفاقم هذه الازمات وتفاقم
معاناه المواطنين في ظل منع الاحتلال دخول
اي مساعدات او دخول اي مواد اساسيه
للاستمرار في الحياه حيث اصبح الاهالي هنا
يقومون بطحن طعام الحيوانات وطعام الدواب
لتحويله الى خبز وس جوعهم هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه كما نشاهد هنا هذا طعام الدواب
وهذه الذره التي تستخدمها العائلات في
شمال قطاع غزه من اجل سد
جوعهم المياه قاعدين احنا بنشرب مياه
ملوثه الاكل ملوث احنا قاعدين هذا هذه
الذره اللي قاعدين بنبيع في الدول الثانيه
لا تصلح للاستعمال الحيواني مش لدمي احنا
قاعدين
بنستعملها الناس مضطره انها تعجن وتخبز
وفي بزبط معهم وفي ما بزبط معاهم احنا
الان في مجاعه رسميه
وحقيقيه احنا في بيئه متلوثه 100 في احنا
مياه ما في لا في ميه ولا في اكل ولا في
شرب ولا في قمح القمح يستعمر فقط للدواب
هذا للدواب ها اللي بستخير منه هي
هذا زبل هذا زبل مش ذره اوب يا رب هيني
بدي انخل انا منه و بفرجيك ايش اللي بنخل
اللي بتنخ سوس وتنخل دود وتنخل حشرات منه
ما بتنخ
طحين هذا هو هي عندك 2 كيلو هي اقل من 2
كيلو هي
زبله يعني قاعدين احنا بناكل زبل ما بناكل
اكل
اوادم
وما بتاكل اصلا البنادمين تع الحيوانات
بنسويها الحين بنحمص وبناكل من القله من
الجوع جعانين احنا الكبار جعانين والاطفال
جعانه كمان ما فيش ولا شغله ولا عمله ولا
حاجه ولاقينا نشتريه في السوق ما فيش ولا
اكل ولا شرب والاولاد كله قاعد من وين
يطلعوا يشتغلوا ببر الدود منه والمعفن
لانه ويته ميه مش قادرين نشتريه لقول الاد
عشاره مابال ابوه وموه قلت لهم حمسو وبر
الدود والوسق منه عشان اطحن واطعمك اولاد
ابني اولاد بنتي كلهم عندي من وين ا جي من
وين 50 نفر عيلتي في الصف ولا عندي غطاء
اتنفا فيه ولا اكل ولا شرب ولا حاجه من
وين
اجيب احنا 200 من الجو اصلا بشتغل بنظف
الجم اكل الدوام من الحشرات والمبيدات
والوسخ وبنط حنوا وبنعمل خبز ناكله جعانين
اكثر حاجه جعانين انت شاي ايش بنساوي
بنطول الدود وبنعمل طحين وبنق مع انه مش
زاكي بس بنا نصبر حالنا على
الجوع هكذا وصل الحال بالاهالي هنا في
شمال قطاع غزه في ظل منع الاحتلال دخول
المواد الاساسيه ومنع الاحتلال دخول
المساعدات اصبح الاهالي يستخدمون طعام
الحيوانات وطعام الدواب اكرمكم الله من
اجل سد جوعهم وجوع اطفالهم هنا في شمال
غزه انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه